after a period of relative cam relative
for this war mind scores of missiles
have evaded Ukraine's defenses and
struck targets across the country
the Russians well they targeted energy
infrastructure power lines power plants
including one nuclear plunging hundreds
of thousands into cold and darkness
but plenty of Civilian targets were also
destroyed either by accident or design
and frankly it's happened so often now
the Assumption has to be they were
targeted intentionally
still the Russians claim the barrage was
in response to what they described as a
terrorist attack on Russian territory in
briansk others point to the bloody
entrenched battles around back moot on
the Eastern Frontier the Russians have
lost tens of thousands of troops
attempting to take and hold a time not
exactly thought of as desperately
strategically significant
with the tempo of the conflict expected
to accelerate significantly as the
country comes out of winter we appear no
closer to a conclusion than on day one
of the war I'm Neil Patterson and this
is the Sky News Daily
our chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
was in Kiev when the attack took place
Ukraine is never going to give up uh I I
just think that that's it this could go
on forever but they're just not going to
give up
we will be healing much more from him
shortly but the story of the day is that
barnage of missiles that struck across
the country we were sent this voice note
from Ukrainian MP Andre osichuk who's in
Cube we had another
a mass missile attack on Ukraine
the officials are reporting that more
than 13 regions were under attack
here is one of them it was and give it
was another morning it was pretty loud
as officials said that air defense was
actively working a number of missiles
were shut down but unfortunately some
missiles reach targets
um I was at home in this cave downtown
they continue hunting on civilians only
they continue targeting civilians but
now we know that it is the the nature of
uh horrific Kremlin regime I'm sure that
we will stay strong and I'm sure that
none of further missiles can change
anything in Ukraine and especially of
our Readiness to fight till the end and
we see that the victory is not our wish
it's upcoming reality
let's bring in our chief correspondent
Stuart Ramsey in Kiev amp Stuart sounds
like a hell of a morning this has been a
pretty big attack by the Russians on
Ukraine 81 missiles of various
descriptions fired across an awful lot
of the country the aim of these attacks
in the past has been to go for the
energy infrastructure of Ukraine to try
and break that down break down normal
life upset the population if you'd like
but a large number of residential areas
and actually even farm houses were hit
as well I've just come back from one
residential area there's about five or
six completely burnt out cars from where
the missiles struck and started a fire
which spread between all of those
Vehicles dozens upon dozens of apartment
Windows as you might expect have been
smashed or cracked from the force of the
blast and people I was asking them you
know are you getting used to this is
It's Gone on for over a year now is the
or something that you just accept is
happening and actually they say they're
not getting used to it they live in fear
at night and they're angry about what's
happening but not one person I've spoken
to has shown any doubt that it's the
right thing that Ukraine keeps fighting
and it's sort of they hope there's going
to be peace but then they're sort of
they accept that even as ordinary
citizens woken in the early morning by a
huge explosion it is something that just
happens to them and they just got to
accept it but but it's terrorizing the
civilian population still you know a
major part of the Russian strategy they
do not have infinite numbers of missiles
and for them to be we presume targeting
these places they're clearly hoping
still that it would have that effect we
hear from the Ukrainian authorities that
Hypersonic missiles uh we use now
President Putin often talks about them
because he describes them as the the
missile that NATO can't beat in fact
nobody can beat because if the speed of
it travels it can't actually be shot
down but he doesn't actually have that
many in the past past has been greater
power outages than we saw from this
particular series of attacks so it may
be that their air defense systems are
just continuing to improve so they could
stop the severity or the implications
from any attack from Russia but it is
wanting as you say to to try to wear the
Ukrainian people down and I have to say
it simply isn't working why was a delay
for three weeks well one theory was that
maybe they're running out of weapons
maybe that's the case difficult to know
but certainly this was a a very
significant event by the Russians and
it's not that it completely unexpected
just I think after three weeks of
relative quiet across the country it is
always comes as a shock to the Ordinary
People Stuart you've mentioned that the
targeting of infrastructure particularly
the power infrastructure How concerned
should we be that the electricity has
been cut off to the nuclear power plant
in separation there is huge concern
about the power plant it's running on
Jan generators at the moment because
it's been being cut off from the grid
and obviously nuclear power plants have
to have electricity continuously so that
they can keep the reactors cool it's
just an accepted given worldwide it's
diesel generators can keep going for 10
days the position seems to be that power
can be reconnected and it can be fixed
both sides of accused the other are
attempting to bomb it or not look after
it correctly and it is very very serious
I mean obviously without power you you
get a meltdown it's the biggest nuclear
power plant in Europe and it really has
to be secured somehow but in this
Dreadful War trying to get agreement
between these two sides is nion
impossible and so the hope is that at
some point everyone will see sense and
they actually it is left alone by all
sides and no soldiers that are even near
it and nobody tries to attack one
another around it but there's not been
much sense talked in this war
particularly from the Russians who who
basically have soldiers there they know
by definition that is going to be an
antagonistic position against the
ukrainians and it there's they're not
both sides are effectively ignoring the
authorities who really need to be able
to control what happens to that nuclear
power station because obviously by
definition this would be a huge huge
incident for the whole of Europe
actually and Russia if it was to melt
down you know we have heard from
president zielinski for quite some time
you know I want more he wants more in
terms of our defense he certainly wants
to get his hands on some fighter jets as
you might expect he he basically
criticized the Russians for attacking
the civilian population of the country
he said you what you don't understand is
that we're not going to give in but you
are trying to terrify people trying to
kill them and that they will be
effectively no surrender from Ukraine
under any other circumstances and I
think what the point you're making
actually is that these type of incidents
at the very least by definition if you
think about it when he asked for air
defense that's obviously a safety
capability for the country the donor
nations are going to supply it because
you need to be able to take these
Rockets missiles and drones out of the
sky when it comes to other more
sophisticated Weaponry where we know
tanks are pretty much on their way will
he get fighter jets he certainly thinks
so he he knows there's a fair amount of
convincing to do but he definitely
believes that eventually he will need
them and that will be a game changer I
suspect it probably could be but
crucially they need huge amounts of
Munitions you know they just actually
need bullets and Rockets of their own
and of course at the same time Russia
does as well I know that's why we're
seeing I think along this sort of 600
mile front line it does a lot of
fighting taking place but a lot of the
time it's actually almost ground to a
halt now some of that's to do with the
weather but mainly I think it's because
both sides are conserving their weapons
for any future offensive they may want
to carry out and ukrainians have made no
secret that they intend to have one of
their own come spring and the Russians
have made no secret that they are
intending to do exactly the same if they
aren't already in fact
foreign
itself our team in Ukraine has also been
speaking to those serving on the ground
first Khalid machiaso a fighter in the
Chechen Battalion in the Ukrainian army
fighting in Batman itself we got someone
in our Newsroom to speak his words so
that you can understand
the city of bakmut is under full control
of Ukrainian forces there are Wagner
fighters on the outskirts their units
are trying to break through into the
city there is heavy fighting the
situation is hard but under control
we're trying to stop them getting inside
there are civilians inside the city they
are hiding in shelters and coming to
humanitarian hubs to get food
sometimes we deliver food there also
there are bodies of civilians and we're
trying to find a way to get them out to
ukrainian-controlled territory fighting
is very intense they're shelling the
city the whole time they're located on
the outskirts and shelling shelling all
the time they're destroying all
residential houses and trying to make a
path for themselves but for now we are
controlling the situation
now let's get an overview from Serie
chalawati the spokesman for the
Ukrainian Joint Forces command in the
east
it's the epicenter of fighting the enemy
is using all its power in this direction
on the outskirts of back moot back moot
is the hottest spot on the front line
the enemy is trying to break our
defensive line but they are failing
Ukrainian forces have been able to get
ammunition and supplies into bakmut they
have also been able to evacuate injured
people from there
why has this time become such a focal
point completely unremarkable City to be
honest in the Donetsk region of the
donbass and of course the reason why
it's significant with the Russians is
because they've made it clear that they
want to clear out and control the whole
of the donbass which currently they
don't that is their objective that was
the objective right from the start and
they have failed so far to do that in
fact the ukrainians have pushed back now
but now is of no great tactical or
strategic value to the Russians because
Beyond it both to the north and to the
South the ukrainians are heavily dug in
and from the south are planning their
own offenses as well and are and are
pretty certain to be able to protect
themselves from the north why are they
doing it well I think it's a lot of a
fight between the Wagner group this is
the mercenary group that has I think
attempted to show the Russian military
that they can actually get a victory
after sort of six months without any and
symbolically show them that they really
mean business and that by Taking Back
mood perhaps the rest of the military
get a g up if you like and that they
perhaps helps their morale I mean twenty
thousand thirty thousand Russian troops
have lost their lives in this battle
already we think it's a case of sort of
five to one Russian soldiers killed for
every Ukrainian and this is going on
absolutely daily huge huge numbers the
Russia the Ukrainian soldiers talk of of
the advancing Russian soldiers as
literally stepping over the bodies of
their comrades who have fallen in front
of many of these guys these mercenaries
are actually ex-convicts they've had
very little training and they're just
basically being used in a very old
Russian military tactic which is you win
because you've just got more people than
anyone else well it's not working here
particularly they have made significant
advances but they haven't been able to
get the ukrainians out at all now I
think what Ahmed has become to Ukraine
interestingly is a simple
of their Defiance and they really don't
want to give it up again it's not
because it means too much to them it's
by no means the biggest city or the most
important in that part of the country so
it really is one that they're just
prepared to fight over what we're
describing here you know in entrenched
dug in positions wave after wave of
attacks it does have that feeling of the
song doesn't it World War one and I have
to say walking through the trenches it
is quite an eerie feeling when you're
doing it because it seems you know
trudging through mud and snow it feels
very odd and very like you know I can't
believe now 2023 that the pictures that
we saw from 14 to 18 19 14 18 World War
One are actually being repeated in this
modern era but they are and I'll tell
you why it's because they're using
effectively the same tactics and that is
basically just to grind each other down
with continuous artillery and that's
exactly what is happening you talked
earlier about the morale
um amongst the civilian population that
had been attacked I wonder what the
morale is like amongst the Ukrainian
troops stationed in those tranches very
good it's dead you know it's been going
on for over a year many are clearly
exhausted uh they get under a new law
about 10 days off a year but all of them
except that logistically that is very
hard to deliver on a guaranteed day and
time but they will get their time off
some have not been home at all and
haven't seen their families and of
course a lot of the families will
actually have left the country as well
so they just sort of committed to the
front line I think we know on on a
battlefield that this is an actual
simple fact it's you can it it takes
less men and it is easier to defend than
it is to attack so the Russians are much
more likely to take casualties and while
Ukraine obviously carries out its own
offensive
Expeditions as well it's worth
remembering that to them it's always
really about defending Ukraine so even
even if the tax is to attack and it is
more dangerous being on the offensive
they're defending their country and I
think you have
um a an army and a volunteer army that
believes in what they're fighting for
haven't been sent from another country
but are actually if we lose here then we
lose everything
Stuart can you conceive of any
circumstances in which president
zielinski would just give up
uh it would just back away and from what
has been going on in Batman I can't see
any any way it was specific about bakmud
yeah he might well he's already gone on
record of saying I'm not going to keep
us fighting there until all of our guys
as we call them are dead he doesn't want
to do that but I think he what he his
advisors and his military have have have
decided is that they actually can
perhaps pull this off but certainly
degrade the Russians to such an extent
as I say that it might be worth doing
but I can't see him if you like the
whole battle he's never they're never
going to give up Ukraine is never going
to give up uh I just think that that's
it this could go on forever but they're
just not going to give up and I think
there's too much International help for
them to need to give up the only way
this comes to an end is some type of
negotiated settlement I believe I can't
see either side either winning or losing
and that's why why you have this this
Dreadful wall just grinds on because
actually we're almost back to where we
started and it's hardly changed after it
went to 2014 if I look at the look at
the maps then and now there's almost no
difference in them at all so we've lost
all these uh soldiers
for actually nothing it's it's
horrendous actually
my thanks to Stuart Ramsey our team in
Ukraine and of course to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Neil Patterson this episode was produced
by soyler Apparition with Alex Eden
Philly Bowman is our editor